ich kenne wirklich gern gegen jeden aber
gegen sich servus heute wir sind gerade
auf den weg zu einem besonderen ort wo
wir er hat schon titel gesehen minecraft
direkt am see spielen werden nicht an
irgendeinem sondern am bodensee das ist
ein gigantisch groß sind ist mal wieder
darüber gemacht 50 milliarden kubikmeter
dass hierbei und ja wir setzen sollte
einfach ein strand und zocken oder
versuchen es zumindest mach ich bin
gespannt ob senat
so leute jetzt sind wir hier vor ort
sondern gerade unter wir müssen es
wirklich beeilen bevor es dunkel wird
auf kurs kommen
very important
ich habe dieser mann hier zocken er ist
für richtige sagte sehe das hier oben
wir haben hier nur 3g wir müssen
natürlich ein mobiles internet die
verbindung machen wenn wir auf dem
server zocken wollen
das könnte tricky werden wir probieren
das motto very important to keep energy
personal hotspot das war ein call center
verband jaaa ich hab mein laptop akku
voll aufgeladen aber dieser laptop ist
scheiße der hat die krassesten spex aber
akkulaufzeit mexiko
4 wenn ich daran denke blende ich euch
jetzt mal die technischen daten vom
laptop ein so leute persönlicher hotspot
ist eiskalt bei facebook ist schon okay
leute kopfhörer seien geschlossen jetzt
begeben uns mal an die file und 10
aber nicht dass das wasser dann steigt
es wird entscheidend beim ausfällt
stellt sich gerade das legen wir keinen
platz
jetzt geht es kommen ja auch in sachen
drauf
ich für meine finger nicht mehr so kalt
hier draußen okay okay wir sind auf dem
server basierten server basierten wasser
steigt und steigt
da passiert noch gar nicht
leute ihr habt keine ahnung
tausende finger gerade sind ihr habt
über auf haltestelle direkt die
schwieriger erster check point s läuft
als letztes in tritt
weiter
ich und meine patienten oder
jawoll von zwei solche stürmer holt
meine finger
die feuerwehren in diesem video noch
abfall
frauenkreis heute 3 grad
das schiff
die reichen wenn diese bis zum
außenseiter gemacht als schaffen
wie die
hier wird den aufstocken
aufgehellt 66
aber muss man nur kurz hinter die gucken
du bist nicht der nicht ganz so viel
draußen
das telefonieren nein korrigiert
der kräfte
ok
egal was kaufen sich mit 1000 sie seien
über 1000 spielen alle brauchen wir auf
jeden fall ist haben halt nur noch kohle
von holzschwert die hand seiner hand
dann hat es fast auch junge leute
fingern und ist erst startet dann so
weit weg
du läufst du hund
es kann ist man trotz ihres sohn möglich
seither ist nichts dran bist du schlecht
spielt mal bei drei grad draußen
der tritt für eure finger funktionieren
nicht hineinversetzen belaufen okay was
einfach video machen was in anderen
eindruck sportplatz
doch
drittel
junge ich hätte wirklich handschuhe
einfachen und das erste modul okay für
mich werden es ist immer noch drei grad
kalt und ich für meine kinder liegt
warum immer schön da bedanken
falls ihr eure finger nicht spürt leute
einfach klappen ok modul 1 geschafft
mein linker mittelfinger fühlt sich an
als mit der brennen also tatsächlich
brennen
das ist rechts aber der typ auch wer
jetzt hier ok modul 3 also es geht so
langsam fort
oh gott ich weiß nicht ob ich da
erinnert aber die hat ja mal ein video
gemacht hat er irgendwie am nördlichsten
punkt europas mein block gespielt die
wii ist entpacken cyborgs oder ein stück
ein hotspot wird er nicht ganz fest sind
um die ecke rum führten muss aber modul
3 abgeschlossen
vier lieder maus ok erster sprung
wirklich geschafft so weit
die finger muss wieder endgültig
amputieren lassen am ende wenn ihr
findet es sollte in der hand wieder
haben nach diesem video
dann spendet doch einfach unter
wer keine ahnung ort
maja wolt weil man ich habe meinen
daumen könnten überleben daumen so der
kürzeste weg wieder mit am wenigsten aus
aber die anderen gar vergessen
der erste ist bei 60 und wir sind bei 42
es ist auf jeden fall für die bedingung
ok ok aufwarten
jawohl modul sechs feuer das kenne ich
eigentlich halblinks gut da würde ich
hier lang gehen
was ist eigentlich gerade von zecken
können zwar daran erinnern wo wir
besitzen
wo wir gerade minecraft wiege spielen es
ist ja mein gott ich hab dich vom
geschafft oh mein gott
wir wollen jetzt schnell ins blut findet
jetzt hier nicht herunterfallen
konzentrier dich okay okay okay okay
okay okay
nein dann schreibe ich diese 100 vorn
nein ich meine hände stellen ab ich muss
kurz vor dem finger reaktivieren leute
aber ich muss die finger gesteckt
sterben auch ganz andere körperteile ab
das war vielleicht nicht weiterkomme nur
die harten kommen kann
die harten kommen die harten kommen
keine ahnung in die gletscherspalte
aber ich habe jetzt schon 600 coins mehr
als letzte runde leute 1600 zu 1000
letzte runde läuft dieser zweite quer
sprung da also der hier geht ja noch
aber der andere da oben das ist der
wirkliche jackie ist nämlich sehr da
arbeiten haben sie auch entschärft
damit sollte ich das ja eigentlich
schaffen dann hätten wir module 7 dann
auch schon durch zwar nur als leid aber
ganz ehrlich wen welches menschen
gewesen auf dieser erde juli ziehen
vielen dank
hier dann das einzige mal muss ich jetzt
keine gedanken über die kühlung macht
los gezogen
der kameramann schwächer leute
verständlicherweise module ab
ich würde wirklich gerne als positives
erzählen aber meine füße sind auch
gerade abgestorben im ziel mit 2 2000
taufen seiter was wir hier im ausschnitt
brot im schnitt fort sondheims
users have to love the way you love ok
mit 2001 kann man schon fast die
richtige rolle spielen wir können sogar
in eisen schwert auf das entscheiden
fussball zu kribbeln begrifflich dafür
sollte er nicht tun
okay das netz der mensch das ist ja der
gewinne schreibt
ich kenne es wirklich gerne und gegen
jeden aber gegen sporting
dieser button den hab ich nämlich auf
dem pc ins niemandsland verband aber auf
dem laptop hat mich gestorben und
geändert und das geht jetzt nicht nur zu
ändern
und ja okay ich will einfach nur
erzählen
vor
so hart es ist so hart leben mein gott
aber ein kleinkind in köln ja ja
es seien leute dokumenten